here's a tricky problem what is root
seven percent of 4 root seven the answer
choices are seven over twenty five four
one over four Twenty Eight and undefined
I'll present two ways to solve this
problem
first root seven percent means root
seven over one hundred of means you
multiply the numbers and then we have 4
root seven root seven multiplied by
itself is equal to seven so this is
equal to seven multiplied by four over
one hundred which equals Twenty Eight
over a hundred which equals seven over
twenty five answer Choice a
now here's a neat trick if you multiply
one number by a factor and you divide
the other number by the same factor
you'll get an equivalent problem you can
also do this in Reverse so let's take
the factor to be root seven the first
number becomes one and the second number
becomes 28. one percent of 28 is equal
to 0.28 which equals 28 over 100 which
equals 7 over 25 and the correct answer
is a